[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you will emerge today's episode being a
better you in life we must each deal
with the hand we are dealt performing
our assigned role to the best of our
capacities but after total atomic
annihilation you may find the hand you
were dealt has been reshuffled yes
gone are the simple days of yesteryear
now the common workmen must also be a
covert operative the farmer a master of
the martial arts the ice-cream man a
nuclear physicist
how will you make sense of it all simple
turn to your official vault-tec training
materials with these powerful tools in
hand you'll learn to make the most of
your natural abilities and better
understand what makes you special use
them to be the best you you can be or
someone even better your survival
depends on it with your future secure
share your newfound knowledge with great
benefit but remember there's power in
diversity sometimes who we are isn't a
choice at all
in fact at a particular point in your
young life you may notice that your body
has begun going through certain
unfamiliar changes no it's not puberty
its mutation thanks to our old pal
radiation your DNA has become more
interesting see here you've now gained
the unique abilities of a marsupial in
exchange for a mild neurological
impairment
[Music]
now you've learned how to be a better
you
you are completely prepared to achieve
your full potential in the role of your
choosing as a hand-picked resident of
vault 76 it is your duty to carefully
review your vault-tec provided films
yearly to fully prepare for the day when
you will emerge okay Todd that was a lot
of fun but I think we all have more
questions now yeah it's will take a
little bit of a deeper dive here and
there's there's a lot to go through and
we'll do our best to explain it the
video does a great job of you know
selling the IDs key parts of it the
mutation part you know it's pretty fun
your character can actually get mutated
but the perk system and how you develop
your character we've done a lot of
interesting things there but let's let's
just jump right in and show you a little
bit of the character creation when you
first start you wake up in the vault its
reclamation day we have a full you know
customize your character like we've had
before it's even better now and a little
bit you get to take your ID badge we
we've added this photo mode in the game
that's really really cool the photo mode
allows you to change the field of view
zoom in zoom out and you'll see all the
filters that are coming up you can do
this both here when you take your badge
it's like a training tutorial for it
then you can do it anytime you want out
in the wild with your friends with dead
enemies with a lot of enemies we've also
added this to our load screen system
there's not a lot of loads in our game
but when you fast travel there's a
little one and so any of the pictures
you've taken there will pop up like a
random deck with along with our curated
photos we really this has came out of a
game jam we do these game jams in the
middle of projects to see what new
features we want to try to get in and
this was one of our favorite ones yeah
it turned out turned out really really
great and fun for socially shareable
stuff to even offline
because your friends and so you know
again make your character as a whole
host of it you can take pictures where
you want you can also anytime in the
game change how your character looks
because you're gonna play a character
for a long time and you can you can swap
out and change your sex anything your
hair everything just so that you don't
feel like well I have to I don't like
how I picked in the very first second
what I look like and a really really
cool feature next we have will show you
stepping out of the vault and the first
level up and kind of dig into that some
so you get your if you hit level two
when you step out you kind of complete
the initial vault thing and the first
thing you do when you level up is pick a
special that you want to increase if you
played previous fallout so we have all
the seven specials and after you pick
the one you want to increase you then
pick a perk in that special so here
we're choosing gladiator which is a
melee perk and then that is a card as
you can see the perk system or the perks
are cards and then you equip those and
every special is a pool of points for
the cards you want to equip and each
card has you know I don't want to say
mana cost but a point cost for how
powerful that card is and do you have
the right special for equipping it right
and is it flexible or my jumping ahead
you have there's some more on that we
can get into and show you how flexible
it is and why we made some of the
choices that we we did let's keep going
and then we can spend some time we see a
more complete character okay this is a
level up to level four so we pick some
more cards we wanted to show you how the
cards themselves rank up okay so you can
pick that card again so by picking
gladiator again you can then combine
that card with the other one to create a
more powerful version but it costs more
points right sometimes you may decide
well I only want the one point version
equipped for my character build versus
the more powerful two point version
because I'm using my strength stats in
some other way and yeah so I think that
probably makes sense yes I hope but
there's more than four levels in the
game either yes they're the levels keep
going up and up and up we don't wanna
make a game where you have to stop
leveling and but we had to make some
very interesting decisions and what that
means for a multiplayer game for balance
so let's let's run the next one where we
see it's a much higher level character I
think it's in the 40s
so here we are and you'll see a
character that's much further along
picking charisma we can talk about
Christmas interesting yeah here's a perk
the less mutations act better with
groups and so you can pick any perk that
you meet the requirements for when you
level up there's no randomness there and
here's what it looks like with a
character that's further along we've
upped the cap for each special to 15
from 10 that allows you no better
balance for which cards you're equipping
and the cards right now go from one
point up to five points in power and
then as you level up more cards become
available I've got a bunch of questions
about that but I won there nope a little
bit okay but I want to ask about
charisma should I ask that later about
good you can talk about that now yeah
yeah Chris how does charisma work in an
online game if we're not talking about
NPCs that you can influence what what is
what is charisma do for you there was
that was a very interesting discussion
amongst the team to try to figure out
what do we do with charisma but it made
sense in a multiplayer game that a
player that invest points in charisma
and collects those cards they can share
those cards with their teammates so
we've developed a system where that that
player that invests can become the
person that makes your entire team more
powerful by sharing those cards we did
throw a few cards in there for the
single-player I think we have one it's
lone wolf as I recall on monitor or a
little wander right right so if you can
still pick something for yzma cards if
you're more of a solo kind of player but
the person that plays in groups all the
time will probably invest more there
cool yeah and you probably saw before
again when you level up you get these
are the cards that come in to the sets
you can pick from when you're level 4 or
5 whatever we also experimented with
well how do we add some more fun to it
and give you more choices and so we have
added because their cards per card packs
and every few levels initially every two
levels you get a perk card pack and that
has a four random cards again you could
have picked these but it gives you some
more interesting choice that you might
not have picked
to give you some flexibility in in your
character and then later on you get them
every five but let's look at a per card
pack opening because they're a ton of
fun we do have gold that one's great you
have gold cards the anime of course you
get a joke and a stick of gum nice and
the gum actually for fun is a very
slight it reduces your hunger for a
while if you chew the gum nice and so
there they're a ton of fun you when you
hit that level and you're like oh it's
level six alright I get a pack you get
to pick your regular perk and then also
see like okay I got these other ones is
there something I want to swap out and
that's I'm gonna good to talk about is
the swapping right of the perks right
because you mentioned that you know it
the packs help you discover something
you might not have known you wanted but
how flexible is a system jams like but
you can sorry Gary good you can swap out
perks anytime generally again to
reiterate when you level up you pick a
special you get a point in that special
which is the pool of points that you can
slot perks into you also get to pick one
perk per level you generally you'll pick
the perk from the special you chose but
you can also pick other perks if you
have available points and then these are
wild cards so every every two levels
from level zero month of time and then
every five levels after you'll get one
of those perk packs and what they allow
you to do is to experiment with some
other builds and cards you might not
normally a played remember you do start
with one point in each special so you
will have unused points from the
beginning to where you can try just
sliding these in right off the bat what
we have found is that that allows
players to go hey what are these luck
perks and why do I really want to search
containers for extra ammo and as you
play a survival gaming Bow Wow getting
extra ammo and containers is really
valuable and those remember you can also
share those perks so if you have perks
to share ammo and you share that on your
team every member of the team can then
find more ammo containers and these all
rank up so eventually you're getting
like huge bonuses amnon ammo or food
you're finding or your carry weights a
big deal on this game a lot of lot of
interesting back-and-forth with
developers and how much you can carry or
not and you know you see those cards at
first you're like well that's not as
cool as being able to do plus 20% damage
with my pistol but in a survival game
being able to carry more means you'll be
able
carry more pistols so you know there's
there's a lot of ways that that
interplay and it's there are so many
cards and here hundreds and you're able
to really do these cool builds and swap
things in and out and then I'm on a team
I have a great perk for this team that
you know not want to carry one wanderer
is a perfect example of that
when wanderer you soon as I play that
when I'm playing solo all the time
because it gives me a bonus to my
experience and damage and as soon as
again I don't see my turn that off
because I'm on a team now it doesn't
work and I'll equip a different car that
I can share with my team so when you say
built you're not really talking about
sitting there and and having multiple
kind of decks you're talking about
having more of a baseline and then
making little changes here and there
quickly and easily is that is that a
kind of a correct way of putting it yeah
your character you're still progressing
the way you would expect in an RPG and
it's kind of growing and growing and
growing so it's kind of what Jeff was
saying you're swapping out a thing here
they're the perk packs can also
sometimes give you a perk that is we
intentionally do this you might get one
or two that from a pack of cards that is
a higher level than you are so it's like
a few levels in shooting distance so you
say like oh I didn't even know that was
a perk maybe I want to pick agility on
my next level up because the game has
given me this other perk and I just want
to try it out the other thing is this is
the multiplayer part of it that when you
hit level 50 you don't get to pick any
you don't get to give out a special
point anymore so that doling out
strengthen to all that stops at level 50
but you still get to pick cards so that
gives us a continuing thing where okay I
hit level 73 and I'm still like you know
what I never got to pick that perk
because again there's hundreds of them
I'll go pick that one I want to try it
out so you're not
but we're still capping the you know the
power curve ramp that in our other games
like a Skyrim or a fallout 4 just like
your character keeps getting more and
more and more and more powerful and we
knew we couldn't really have that in
this one you talked about the discovery
of perks too and how you might discover
them in a card pack you might see your
friend using one that you never thought
you'd use have any of you in your own
internal playtesting found a perk that
you never thought you would use that
you're like wow this is really
all the time examples I remember when I
first started playing the game I did
exactly what what Todd alluded to or
Jeff where I've always picked the
percent damage perk
I'm thinking okay I just want to do more
damage as I played the game and
discovered there's a lot of value in
doing things like building up your camp
and doing a lot of exploration and
gathering resources I started to
actually take purse I would have never
picked in a single player game to reduce
the amount things weigh so that I could
actually carry more junk so I can then
bring that back to my camp and I find
that I'd swap that out a lot like if I'm
playing by myself and doing more
exploration I tend to use those kinds of
perks but if I play in a group we
typically have some objective in mind
it's something we want to go and kill
then I might swap some of those out for
the more traditional damage perks
yeah Jeff anything for you that that
emerged recently that you didn't think
you would use but now you're using in
particular I did get to one of those
weird mutations the other day though
they're a lot of fun too so I was
playing and all of a sudden when you
have a lot of rads is when you're
susceptible to mutations like in real
life and then I got a mutation called
bird bone but I didn't realize that
gotten an office and I was over a quote
which is always a frustrating experience
in a game and I'm like why am i over
equipped and I looked and I had this
perk in that let me jump extra I put it
but it lowered my strength so I again
like the way the dynamic systems work is
incredible and you can spend a lot of
time in that perk menu but remember it
is a live game so make sure you're in a
safe place and then I have another
question who gets to write the jokes in
the gum wrappers that is mo Pagliarulo
are you know he does all the master of
the the means for a long time he wrote
the arrow in the knee there wasn't
really a joke he came it became a joke
the poor guy animal animal wrote all
those
you